these people have recently heard prime
minister abdullah the first to hold the
position following sudan's 2018
revolution has resigned and many in the
country are divided on his departure
departure is a big loss to the nation he
had made a lot of achievements and
brought progress to sudan but the
military were the reason he was unable
to move forward on so many issues the
military is the reason we're in this
crisis
it doesn't make a difference just like
he doesn't make a difference if he stays
hamdock no longer serves the demands of
the people on the street he legitimized
a takeover and blessed what they have
done and this was much less than what
the people of sudan have been calling
for
hamduk was sworn in in 2019
after the overthrow of long-time
president ahmad al-bashir he was picked
by the coalition known as the forces of
freedom and change to lead sudan's
transition to democracy the coalition
represented the protest movement that
led anti-government demonstrations
against bashir's government but in past
months the coalition has been divided
that became the basis for the military
to stage a takeover in october placing
hamduck under house arrest and putting
members of his cabinet in prison a month
later he was released and then signed a
deal to form a government of technocrats
sidelining political groups when he
first took office hamdurk's popularity
was high among the protesters and when
he was placed under house arrest during
the military takeover many regarded him
as a symbol of civilian rule but the
deal he signed with the military in
november made him lose support of not
just the protest movement but also of
the political parties that brought him
to power
some activists say hamdok's resignation
could be in the interest of the protest
movement now that hamduk has stepped
down they realize that they need to get
their houses into order they need to get
there you know they need to get
everything organized they need to start
from scratch
and i think also the military side needs
to understand that the people will not
let up hamduck has cited lack of
consensus among political parties as his
reason for stepping down and as the
political parties remain at odds there's
little hope of both coming together to
name someone to replace him hiba morgan
al jazeera